bonsoir heureux de vous avoir sur le
plateau de tout le monde en parle
laurent tu connais jean rochefort
non jean rochefort elle me dit quelque
chose vient nous devons faire un nom ça
va à la pêche écoutez ça va pas mal
ouais alors la moustache au départ vous
aviez laissé pousser la moustache pour
jouer alceste dans le misanthrope et
puis vous l'avais gardé parce que vous
dites que comme vous n'êtes pas beaucoup
de lèvres supérieures quand vous avez
joué la moustache ça vous donne un air
un peu hypocrite oui à l'ère de traîtres
mais alors ça me limitais dans les
contacts féminins dans la fiction alors
vous avez la forme comme votre ami
johnny hallyday vous avez vu on ne parle
que d'être géniale idée c'est incroyable
quand même la france se donne à johnny
hallyday comme elle s'est donnée à
jacques chirac il ya un an au maréchal
pétain à l'époque c'est fou non le
troisième âge trayons vrai mais c'est
assez c'est assez incroyable alors vous
vous êtes devenu un fan de johnny
hallyday quand vous avez fait le film de
patrice leconte l'homme du train
ça s'est bien passé vous avez très bien
j'ai rencontré là un homme modeste et
timide
qui étaient inquiets de tourner avec
nous c'est vrai qu'avant de commencer le
tournage avec johnny vous aviez des
préjugés un petit peu comme tout le
monde sur lui non pensé qu'il était un
peu un peu demeuré ou non pas demeurer
ja je ne connaissais que par
les premières pages des journaux n jeu
devrait sortir bourré d'une boîte de
nuit - des choses que ça perdure au bras
d'une jeune femme léonard
et non non mais c'est vrai que c'est
excellent fixez vous des anecdotes bosch
foroches rochefort jean rochefort
irak
sans recevoir mes ados lag mais si votre
rochefort où ces courageux et gauthier
quoi jean enfin jean rochefort je
connais pas les espoirs moi je
voulais une anecdote sur johnny oui
voilà bah alors écoutez bien ça nous
sommes dans une salle à manger ni au
rustique à 10 km de la belle ville
d'annonay en train de dîner
nous sommes quatre il est 10 heures du
soir banlieue d'hanoi à son préparateur
physique
son photographe souffre douleur
et moi même
salle est déserte
et tout à coup une vingtaine de jeunes
gens éclectique avec attaché-case
faisant un séminaire entre dans le
brouhaha parfait
et tout à coup à cette table où il ya
tous ces jeunes gens un silence total et
ce silence est totale parce que là de
liens de s'apercevoir que en banlieue
d'annonay à la table occupé il y à
johnny hallyday
ces jeunes gens continuent à dinéault
cependant la fourchette dans la joue
parce qu'il fixe les analyser et au
dessert johnny ayant bu deux ou trois
bières de bordeaux parle un peu plus
fort et ces jeunes gens entendent jeunes
idir dit donjon est ici à 10 ans
vendredi
elle m'a fait un potage au potiron
tu veux guingamp descend un thermos
j'ai vu 20 types broyer
le look parfait c'est un garçon sympa
et oui mais qui cherche pas trop j'ai
échangé de cette merveilleuse
authenticité qui fait son triomphe tout
à fait genre et vous n'avez vu aussi des
mecs qui marchaient à quatre pattes pour
ramasser les mégots qui ont amassé un
mégot qui l'avait fait tomber
il ya un type qui l'a ramassée et mis
dans sa bouche j'étais au bord des
larmes mois là vous le vouliez c'est pas
que je le voulais j'ai arrêté de fumer
il ya longtemps mais ça fait de la peine
ce qui est très marrant c'est qu'il ya
longtemps à l'époque où picollier un peu
vous passiez vous dites des soirées
ampleur en vous disant mais que va faire
johnny quand il sera vieux je prenais de
temps en temps des cuites phénoménal en
bretagne un pléonasme s'y mettent aussi
bon endroit mono juhasz c'était odieux
que fera johnny quand il fera quand il
sera prêt et je ne savais pas imaginer
non il est toujours là il prend pas sa
retraite il a 43 ans de cotisations et
c'est vrai que par rapport au reste de
la france aujourd'hui ça fait ça fait un
peu tache alors
vous en parle on ne savait jamais été
très très engagé politiquement on n'a
jamais su très bien de quel bord vous
alors à thiais oui alors c'est ça je ne
suis pas d'un bord précis je ne suis pas
un homme de groupe je suis profondément
individualiste mais avec une profonde
tendresse pour mon espèce
qu'il fait beaucoup de peine et de plus
en plus de peine l'homme est un loup
pour l'homme est un prédateur c'est oui
c'est le sol pratiquement sur la planète
avec quelques insectes 1 et les
chimpanzés on sait maintenant que trois
ou quatre mâles chimpanzés peuvent
parcourir des centaines des centaines de
kilomètres arrivé sur un territoire qui
n'est pas le territoire de leurs voisins
assassiné un mâle est parti s'échappant
américain ça non mais non ils sont
partout à cannes j'avais beaucoup bu
d'américains quand vous étiez
le jury du festival non j'en ai vu un
qui était dedans le jour avec moi
soderbergh avec lequel je me suis bien
entendu ouais je me passais par genre
sexe amour et vidéos
s'enregistrent faire un jeu parce qu'il
a envie d'en sortir je ne connais cette
moustache
j'aimerais qu'ils gardent un bon
souvenir de vous à cannes c'est votre
chauffeur qui s'en cale ça je le connais
très bien
très sympathique simple chauffeur de de
gens à cannes et alors il a déclaré dans
nice matin les années après notre
histoire jambes m'a plus jamais rappelé
je sais pas vous l'avais complètement
séduit et abandonner si j'ai passé un
bon ben je vais l'appeler oui c'est très
amoureux de vous et ont une envie c'est
un homme tout à fait des bisous nouvelle
plus d'un banal bien mais je vais faire
attention c'est d'appeler avec la
lessive venu ici avec quelqu'un de chez
vous momo minutes à bruz arriveront
absolu sur platon charmoy bravade et de
plein de choses fondamentales le
palmarès la can comme un peu bizarre non
vous l'avez fait exprès ou quoi l'écouté
l'affairé délicate
l'affairé délicate on n'avait pas grand
choix enfin il et karin viard comme est
très sympa quand même eu un très très
très sain extrêmement brillant c'est
très sympa c'est qu'elle est venu ici
car il ya ça ne m'étonne je lui ai
demandé un jour je lui ai dit karine
qu'est ce que vous préférez dans le sexe
elle n'a répondu l'habite
bon match et non mais attends juste et
vous que ta cb en même temps quand on
réussissait pas ces parisiens
elle se tait c'était avant la crise qui
va c'était bien avant nombreux au pad au
festival de cannes nous avons subi une
fellation de huit minutes et demie c'est
quand même loin et demi et ça m'a fait
raser les murs pendant des semaines
parce que l'homme avait un sexy morts
j'ai appris récemment que c'était une
prothèse ou alors j'ai retrouvé de
et dites moi j'emmène ryan vous l'avez
brancher un peu chaque valian jeu les
branches et j'ai eu à passer ah oui oui
je mets ça s'est passé divinement bien
avec miss univers la crise annuelle ah
oui qu'est ce qu'elle est belle elle est
magnifique et elle m'a laissé un petit
papy la ville des petits bijoux
incrustés incrusté dans le carton des
petits de pacotille donc quoi exotique
mais avec love jusque j'aime ça en fait
ce que je préfère chez vous j'en sais
votre timidité c'est dire que dans les
films de dont on parle toujours
l'éléphant ça trompe énormément nous
irons tous au paradis cette espèce de
timidité que vous avez comme ça je
trouve ça touchant je trouve ça très
craquant j'aime les émerveille encore
est une jeune femme comme ça mais
ophélie winter a voulu m'embrasser de
recoller à la belle était trop bâti une
pré taxi râteau n'est qu'un projet
patron mais enfin ça bouleverse donc
vous avez toujours été comme samedi avec
les filles à l'âge de 22 ans fumer la
pipe dans votre coin et puis vous
appelez le philosophe quoi vous aviez du
mal à j'étais très timide je n'entrais
pas dans le jeu j'en ai beaucoup
souffert et puis c'est venu petit à
petit
l'acquisition de la moustache aussi je
pense a tous la touffe les libérer et ça
fait pas c'est vrai que vous vous étiez
plutôt partisan de choses comme ça on
faisait des on se faisait un petit
baiser le soir quand les parents étaient
partis en fait c'était vous dire est
effondré quand vous voyez les films
pornos aujourd'hui à la télé ou même
même les émissions de télévision est en
tout cas ne pensez pas que je sois un
homme austère en béton je vais je passe
pour un amant exceptionnel
mais c'est vrai il est vrai que que
l'hypocrisie dans la sexualité est resté
pour moi stimuli avantage way et il est
vrai que le sexe exposés et ce qu'a
profondément ma libido bah oui parce
qu'il ya plus de transgression a lâché 2
à la grosse question je suis
baudelairien c'est connaître la
sexualité dans les toilettes d'une école
communale c'est là que mon tout
viendrait de gens
alors c'est tout un monde que je
découvre maintenant et c'est vrai que
cet affichage permanent américain de
boukman actuellement alors vous êtes
devenus cultes maintenant parce que
c'est vrai que bonvoisin fait le film
blanche avec vous chabal et robin des
bois à saillé quoi j aulas vous êtes
dans une autre dimension c'est encore ce
encore ailleurs la non oui oui c'est
vrai je suis en train de vivre un
hommage posthume de mon vivant ce qui
est mieux donc on en profite c'est
arrivé parce que il ya eu déjà deux
césar y est que la fête commence et le
crabe tambour et en 99 un césar
d'honneur ça sent le sapin cm ça voulait
dire allez hop là on a cru qu'il allait
ouvrir ouais ça fait un truc qui avait
mourir et puis voilà et puis finalement
non vous êtes toujours là malgré votre
césar d'honneur édition mais qu il m'a
porté la poisse
ils sont bien failli avoir raison alors
on y arrive on y arrive parce qu'il ya
un film qui n'aura jamais de césar
un film qui ne sortira jamais mesdames
messieurs l'homme qui tua don quichotte
terry gilliam avec johnny depp vanessa
paradis et notre ami jean rochefort qui
a très mal commencé d'abord il y avait
les journées litres déjà déjà le type
qui ensuite il y avait dès le début du
tournage il y avait des avions de vous
avez tourné juste en dessous des avions
de chasse qui faisait un bruit infernal
toute la journée il ya eu un orage qui
emporte en paix tu fais le tu emploies
la tue tout le décor c'était déjà
terrible et alors huit jours après le
début du tournage vous j'en reçois vous
êtes victime d'une hernie inguinale
oui et entre autres ça a été plus
compliqué que ça on ne le fait pas de
réponse sur mes petits malheurs mais
aussi s'il ya eu un vrai désastre
officio logique tout à craquer donc le
dos la hernie inguinale
dernière dans le périnée est alors 1ère
place et affreusement pour perrine et ça
fait mal quand périnée et ça fait très
mal et obligé d'arrêter le tournage et
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que vous
dans votre carrière j'ai fait quoi 150
films - jamais arrêté un jour même mais
j'aime même manqué un jour jamais 20 ans
de théâtre ou des soirées cent trente et
quelques films donc j'étais vraiment
broyés par cette chose là d'autant que
c'était parlons un peu sérieusement que
c'était un peu un rêve pour moi terry
gilliam était un rêve johnny depp était
un fan parce que j'adorais ces films qui
avait fait avec jarmusch odieux et là
vous dites johnny depp qui a qui est un
petit peu de sang indien il a ce respect
des personnages et
l'univers vous avec beaucoup de beaucoup
d'attentions beaucoup de chaleur venue
c'est un homme épatant 1 ça a été comme
une espèce de fils
artistiques comme ça il
ils ont été épatants tous les deux avec
vanessa comme deux enfants s'apercevant
papa va mourir
j'espérais que j'allais vous vous
remettre tout le monde a tout fait mais
en fait pas du tout c'est à dire que
d'abord on a cru un moment où vous avez
le cancer vérité voilà quoi est ce qui
n'était pas le cas malgré le césar
d'honneur et vous êtes resté sept mois
au lit et là votre françoise a été
formidable de petits aujourd'hui elle
dit moi je suis rentré chez moi donc la
douleur j'ai demandé à ma femme c'est
bizarre comme le psychisme et
physiologiquement enfin c'est pareil jeu
après deux là maintenant j'ai voulu
faire des photos que ma femme me
prennent en photo avec une fourchette
une râpe à à gruyères et une espèce de
timbale en métal pour qu'elles prennent
des photos de moi totalement dérisoire
en quichotte et on a fait cette série de
photos que je dis toujours pas regardé
et je suis monté dans ma chambre et je
suis resté couché sept mois mais j'ai
voulu avant de me coucher faire ces
photos pour me piétiner la queue
derrière une idée comme une dernière
pitreries quoi oui alors bon au départ
tout le monde espère vous remettre un
jour voilà il réalise que le film se
fera jamais vous avez beaucoup de mal à
en parler jusqu'au jour où à londres
vous assister à la projection du making
of du film pascaline équipe qui tournait
qui a filmé ces espèces de désastre
gigantesque ça a été l'équipe c qui fut
l'automne et louis pépé donc qu'ils ont
fait ce soleil offre et le making off
s'appelle lost in la mancha perdu dans
la mancha donc évidemment c'est bien
l'histoire et je trouve moi que le fait
finalement que le fil soit pas fait et
qui ce making of sur le fait que le film
était un échec c'est beaucoup plus
quichaud tient tout à cesser ses pires
ans des liens c'est que c'est des gros
on met ces gens délicieusement absurde
oui making of mais il n'y a pas deux
offres voilà c'est le seul si voilà
c'est le seul film qui n'existe pas et
qu'on voit à travers un making-of alors
woody allen a déclaré au sujet de ce
making of c'est le pire cauchemar qu'un
réalisateur puisse vivre mais c'est
tellement réjouissant encore une toute
petite chose minuscule je voudrais pas
qu'on croie que je suis incapable de
faire marcher un cheval au pas pu se
consacrer la moitié de ma vie à sa wii
et dans l'est dans les catastrophes
supplémentaires ce cheval est mort le
lendemain ou pieux tout simplement parce
que on avait décidé pour qu'il ait l'air
de rossinante de ne pas lui donner à
bouffer pendant trois mois un bonjour la
spa mais bonjour le spleen de rochefort
tout ça ça m'a foutu un coup tu régime
un gta régalez vous tiens vous n'avez
pas de gueuler on est chez moi mais ma
tête mais je les inclus la force doit
alors complètement non non je ne peux
plus monter si terrible parce que vous
avez un rapport au cheval qui est qui
est très intéressant c'est à dire que
vous avez été mais les tréteaux au monde
du cheval puisque votre grand père avait
une compagnie de fiacre a dit non et
vous n'êtes pas bon en fait vous montiez
pas malgré ça et à l'âge de 30 ans il
pas non plus tout jeune vous faites
cartouches vous montez à ce moment là
sur un cheval et vous n'entendrez jamais
c'est à dire oui j'arrête la compétition
à 48 ans avaient alors pourquoi vouliez
pas monté sur un cheval je crois que
c'est parce que vous aviez peur d'avilir
lallaoui noble conquête de l'homme pense
que
j'ai assez le respect des des êtres pas
des choses mais des êtres et je pensais
qu'on n'avait pas le droit de monter sur
le dos de l'animal ou d'un homme ouais
ça me gênait beaucoup je voulais courir
à côté ça énervait mon père mais alors
c'est pour ça que j'ai
j'ai réussi très tard fait à la fois
d'après ce qui est incroyable c'est
quand vous montez sur un cheval à l'âge
de 30 ans
il ya quelque chose qu'il se réveille en
vous au niveau génétique quoi parce que
cette famille était là dedans en quoi
vous devenez complètement fou de cheval
mais ça devient pour vous une passion
pratiquement à 50 50 avec le cinéma est
un métier mais alors lui une histoire
extraordinaire c'est un jour jean est à
saint lô dans une foire et puis à un
type qui s'approche la vieille éleveurs
normands hui cheveux comme ça grince
sous la casquette en tweed un gros pif
tout rouge c'était à saint lô c'était la
vente des étalons de l'année voit déjà
proche de moi et me division chez vu
avec la télé je serai protégé du cinéma
oh
alors j'en sors comme vous êtes en très
bonne santé tout le monde peut le
constater c'est le moment de vous faire
une interview jugement dernier
c'est l'heure du jugement dernier
jean hétu près pas encore mais bon
genre oui hein tu cru en moi
à une époque oui pourquoi as-tu cessé de
croire en moi gens
parce que j'ai cessé parce que j'y ai
cru en vous par trouille de la mort et
je sais que vous n'arrange rien là haut
tu fais chier enfin jean
as-tu déjà pêché par penser par action
par omission ou à la mouche
pêcher à la mouche jamais
par omission jamais ai pas repensé tout
le temps
genre
tu foutu en l'air un tournage en
prétextant un quelconque eu mal au dos
non j'ai foutu en l'air un tournage en
prétextant une douleur dans le périnée
qui est située entre l'anus et
testicules
jean
as-tu déjà participé à des émissions de
télévision sous l'emprise de substances
illicites
non mais ce soir j'aurais dû
jean
as-tu déjà regardé tf1 le samedi soir en
deuxième partie de soirée non non jamais
pourvu que ça dure
tu déjà commis l'acte de chair sans
volonté reproductrices
oui de nombreuses fois et j'en garde un
souvenir est pas tant la plaie jean
desailly une époque
à bien des cas du genre
as-tu déjà trompé ta maîtresse
non je ne suis pas un trompeur j'ai eu
de grandes passions mais je ne trompais
pas je partais est ce que tu te reposes
tous tes péchés gens non c'était le plus
agréable et corrections de ne rien rater
le in a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu